life is slowly returning to the
neighborhood around the UN in New York
after three months in which this city
was one of the global hot spots of kovat
19 but United Nations headquarters
itself stays closed only essential staff
have been allowed in the building since
the 16th of March it's a place that's
been transformed on the floors markers 2
meters or 6 feet apart to show physical
distancing rules masks must be worn when
close to others and the elevators are
now limited to 2 occupants normally on a
weekday well over 10,000 people pass
through these gates on some recent days
the numbers have been well below 100
when you take a walk in the corridors
you see virtually nobody cafes are
shuttered conference rooms are closed
and the places where ambassadors and
officials used to brief reporters a
silent while there's just a skeleton UN
staff working the number of cleaning
crews has been increased it's possible
that the glass steel and marble here has
never gleamed this much in the
neighborhood around the UN where many
diplomats and officials live life is
slowly returning to normal from Monday
with new Co grid 19 rules many shops and
businesses across New York City can
reopen for the first time but inside the
UN things will remain closed this is the
main visitors Lobby
it's normally teeming with people and
I'm the only person here normally there
are diplomats from all over the world
it's a melting pot but that's the
problem it could become a fresh
incubator for the virus the
secretary-general Antonio Guterres has
ordered that a phase reopening of the
complex won't start until August at the
earliest James BAE's al Jazeera at the
United Nations